si la tendance se maintient on aura la
prochaine élection un mode de scrutin
proportionnel mixte compensatoire avec
liste régionale qui veut comprendre
monsieur
l'idée c'est que la représentation à
l'assemblée nationale soit
proportionnelle aux voix exprimées
pensons à la cac qui se retrouve avec 59
% des sièges alors que là seulement
obtenu 39% des votes
son chef s'est entendu en mai avec le
parti québécois et québec solidaire pour
réformer le mode de scrutin qui apporte
un gouvernement qui était vu par une
minorité de québécois soit capable quand
des décisions pour une majorité ce qu'on
entend par mixte c'est d'avoir moins de
circonscriptions où des députés sont
élus avec le mode de scrutin actuel
plutôt que 125
supposons 75 comme aux élections
fédérales mais y aurait 50 sièges de
plus dit compensatoires attribué en
proportion des votes donc dans les
régions on se retrouverait avec le même
nombre de députés qu'actuellement
par exemple si l'ensemble des québécois
votent à 40% pour un parti mais que ce
parti obtient 25 sièges il recevrait 25
sièges de compensation pour un total de
50 des 125 députés
ces sièges seraient répartis dans les
différentes régions en fonction des voix
obtenues et pour déterminer qui sera élu
il y aurait des listes régionales de
candidats préalablement soumise par le
parti vous vous dites c'est bien trop
compliqué pourtant ça existe dans quatre
pays dans le monde dont l'allemagne
maintenant le découpage des
circonscriptions et des régions et
l'organisation des listes doivent entre
autres être négocié faire consensus
parmi les partis et obtenir une
acceptabilité sociale de la population
et c'est là que ça pourrait devenir
compliqué voire mener à une impasse
comme on l'a vu récemment à ottawa où le
premier ministre justin trudeau a tout
simplement abandonné le projet
c'est pas pour pouvoir cocher une case
dans un tract on mérite orale que je
veux faire quelque chose qui provoque
pour les canadiens